voilà le pass suspendu de la cigogne de
theo angelopoulos alors dans le film à
un moment donc on vous met en présence
de mastroianni
vous savez pas si c'est lui enfin vous
dit que c'est pas lui en tous les cas
par contre vous vous l'avez vraiment
retrouvez-vous n'est pas ton ait eu
depuis l'annoncé d'antonioni absolument
samedi 30 mai c'est marrant parce qu'on
n'avait pas l'impression de s'être
quittés et c'était marrant de se
retrouver parce qu'on a retrouvé l'homme
et la femme qui s'était connu surtout
qu'on avait été très amoureux l'un de
l'autre et on s'y retrouvait changé mais
pas mal vous l'aviez pas rencontrés
depuis trente ans aussi dans les
festivals de cannes sur mon nom non pas
vraiment bon mais on savait qu'on
existait on a repris des conversations
qu'on n'avait pas terminé